tell people what's the funnest moment
that we share together working together
for four years what's the fun or
funniest moment we had when you
graduated why was that funny
[Music]
today's the kickoff for National Nurses
Week where we honor and celebrate all
the many roles that nurses play every
single day they truly are the backbone
and frontline of the health care
industry why was that funny because I
had to give a speech and what did you
say and Michael did not get I said right
now I could use a nice tall White
Russian people who got to joke loved it
but yeah well not everyone's an
alcoholic like you kidding especially my
White Russians as you can tell I'm
really close with the nurses I've been
working with for the past few years I
truly appreciate the work that they do
and that's why I get so mad when I watch
Grey's Anatomy or the good doctor and I
see that their work is minimized it
shouldn't be that way and I think nurses
deserve more credit right of it it's
late but I have a question for you what
would you think one of your duties that
would surprise other people that you do
as a nurse you know give me something
the nurse does majority of the education
when it comes to medications alone care
and with the vaccines that we administer
to the children right when's the last
time you seen a doctor give a vaccine
only our residents when they're making
their numbers exactly that's it unless
you've been personally admitted into a
hospital or maybe spend time with a
loved one who has been admitted to a
hospital it's difficult to know the
entire scope of what a nurse does day to
day and those duties are really
remarkable they care for your physical
health they care for your emotional
health they evaluate how well your
treatments going and something maybe
some doctors are reluctant to say but
they really do alert us when we make
mistakes in a reality doctors don't save
lives you save lives doctors save life
as well well my team what I
it's absolutely teamwork yeah absolutely
yeah what makes it a lot easier to get
up in the morning and come to a 16-hour
shift or a 12-hour shift is that
I have fun with my nurses we have a good
time like a genuinely good time we're
laughing we're talking we're sharing our
experiences I think that ability to take
a very stressful situation a very somber
situation and turn it into something
light-hearted and fun and interesting is
a great quality for a nurse to have not
only for patients but also for other
members of the healthcare team like us
doctors now I know some of you may be in
nursing or considering becoming a nurse
and there's a couple of points I want to
make about the career it's one of the
most noble rewarding careers out there
it has amazing job security for the next
few decades the demand for nurses is
only gonna go up and up and up on top of
that you have such a broad scope of
practice meaning you can work in a
hospital in the nursing home and
administration the medical world is
truly your oyster people are often quick
to write off the nursing field based on
others expectations of what the job is
or they're quick to love the field based
on something that they overheard or
something that they projected onto the
field I think you really need to spend
some time with a nurse walk into a
hospital volunteer at a nursing home
spend some time with nurses to find out
what their day-to-day is like if you're
gonna make this your occupation and
you're gonna practice this for 20 30
maybe even 40 years you need to know if
you truly love this field or not and the
way to find that out is by diving in and
stepping outside of your comfort zone so
if they're curious or think that they
want to become a nurse
what's a good step for them to take
preliminaries should they just apply
right away or should they do some more
research we definitely encourage you to
try to get you know experience on the
bedside that develops your your
assessment skills your communication
skills not only with the patient
themselves with family members now even
though I'm a doctor I do have some
advice for aspiring nurses out there
before you take someone else's advice of
why you shouldn't go into nursing or why
you should go into nursing you really
need to figure out if it's a career
that's right for you being a nurse is a
demanding occupation at times you're
working crazy long shifts spending that
time standing on your feet sometimes you
have to give up your holidays where you
would be spending time with loved ones
and in
that are taking care of complete
strangers and sometimes worst of all you
may not receive the gratitude you truly
deserve both from patients and doctors
I've heard this said once before I don't
even remember the context but being and
becoming a nurse is hard but it's the
hard that makes it special to all the
nurses out there happy Nurses Week and
from the bottom of my heart thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thanks everybody for all you do you
still party I know you play Michael go
right now okay
[Music]